apple
security chief offered ipads as a bribe
for
gun permits prosecutors allege thomas
moyer allegedly promised to give 200
ipads to santa clara county sheriff's
office to get
four concealed carry licenses according
to jeffrey rosen district attorney
of the bay area county where apple is
based the charges are part of a broader
probing to the sheriff's office two
high-ranking sheriff's office officials
under chief rick sunk and captain james
jensen
were indicted on a charge of requesting
the bribe the two men
requesting the bribe the two men held
back on issuing the permits until moyer
agreed to donate close to
70 000 worth of ipads says rosen the
donation was pulled back at the 11th
hour when our search warrants into this
probe
began what are your thoughts on this mic
well first of all so that's 50 ipads per
license
right 200 ipads for four licenses for
license that's a good word
yeah i mean so uh to me i think it just
highlights the uh the hypocrisy of
of companies like apple uh you know or
hollywood or what have you and that
you know they they try to get things
that they don't want you to do it's the
same thing with politicians that have
you know bodyguards that want to strip
second amendment or or
you know cancel concealed carry or have
all these different bans and things of
that nature
when the reality is is that you know
people want what they want whether it's
ipads or permits or
uh to be able to carry guns or whatever
but you know it's just that classic
uh rules for the not for me you know
type of mentality that i think drives a
lot of people crazy and just builds
resentment
adam what do you think so i've got a
point and then a question for you
because i want to kick it back to you so
i mean i'm just going off of one of
our good friend thomas moyer who's the
uh
the employee of apple over here his
employee i'm sorry his attorney says
look
there's two different stories going on
here there's two completely different
stories here
and you're mixing them into one first
story is yeah we were looking to donate
some ipads to the sheriff to the
sheriff's uh yeah
to the to the people of the sheriff's
office cool all right and we were also
uh applying for uh our license to carry
license you are completely completing
these two things
so whether that's just lawyer speak we
all know what lawyers do kind of just
complete two
things if that's lawyer speak or if an
actuality was
um you know a paper play uh pay for play
a quid pro quo
a term that we've all learned over the
last few years but was one of those
things
so who knows this is you know obviously
an interesting story to bring up
apple did they they they paid for this
was it a bribe what was it
my question to you is though let's say
this was
crony capitalism almost yep i want to
kick it back to you i know that you
obviously love
capitalism you stand for it you got a
capitalism tattoo basically
but crony capitalism is something that
you hate so where does this fall on the
capitalism bribe crony capitalism chart
and the pbd world well remember who
started it though
you're talking about the politicians the
local guys said if you give
us xyz we will give you xyz
right so it's started by the politicians
there you go okay so the politicians are
the ones that are coming and saying if
you give us this we'll give you this
and then the capitalist is tempted to
think about whether he's going to do it
or not right so whether he's going to
make that decision to say
i'll give you the ipads what the hell is
70 dollars for me to give to you
but i think it's i think it's bigger
than that i think it's
it's the hypocrisy part that's the most
unattractive thing
out there when it comes down to anything
to do with if you ever think about
uh issues you had with your dad why did
you have issues with your with your dad
your dad smoking a cigarette and saying
what
don't smoke cigarettes you know your
your your dad's drinking alcohol saying
what
don't drink alcohol these guys are
saying guns are bad and then at the same
time they want a license to carry
these don't go together especially in
the county that they're in another thing
i would say
you know to to debunk or at least debate
the lawyers i would say okay
you're you're offering to to donate
these uh these objects right or these
ipads
what other institution government-wise
have you offered to donate
ipads to right and if there's like nine
other
parts of the government where where this
guy from apple has has offered to donate
where he's getting jack [ __ ] from them
then i would say okay you have a point
if that's the only group
that he's offered to donate ipads and
i'd say dude
that's not a coincidence smells fishy is
what you're saying yeah i mean
he's got a great point though he's got a
great point because now i don't know if
they can investigate or not because if
if apple's the biggest employer there
it's that employer is probably doing the
most for that county
if an employer is doing the most for a
county they're kind of forgiving a
little bit it's like hey listen
if you screw screw us up we're the one
that's given to a lot of charity a lot
of stuff locally and apple's not known
for
giving money to charity apple's never
been known for being someone that
gives money away never historically
never steve jobs was never known for
wanting to give money away
well here's i guess here's the question
and and you would know this probably
more than most and and we've had an
experience how difficult is it to get a
concealed license in new york it's
almost impossible new york
yeah because this is in california i
mean so same thing
uh sorry i meant california but those
two states both two states are almost
impossible
well let me put it this way when i was
an active duty navy seal in california i
couldn't get a concealed weapons permit
active duty navy seal you could not get
a conversation like right after 9 11 if
i applied and i knew a lot of guys that
did that all got denied i didn't even do
it because
at that time and i'm sure it's still the
same way is that you have to pay
and it's hundreds of dollars to pay uh
to apply for the permit
whether you whether you get it or not uh
but also i mean this is something most
people don't uh don't realize
is that even uh you know and this
gentleman the same same way is that
every base in america as an active duty
uh
military service member you can't bring
a gun on base
so i can go there and shoot rockets and
automatic machine guns and sniper rifles
and lasers that'll take your eyes out
and things of that nature call in close
air support
but i can't have my pistol in my car
driving on to base
so who's creating these rules what is
that bill clinton is responsible for
that one when
during his term he made a national
mandate
or an executive order rather why it
hasn't been rescinded is beyond me but
so i would i would still blame all
subsequent presidents uh that haven't
rescinded it however california and new
york are unquestionably the two hardest
states to get uh concealed weapons
permits and it starts with the governor
the reason that i
even asked that question is because we
recently had jarrah come here and that
assumed was that the clash that she was
teaching yeah she was just licensed to
carry permit
and jarrah who's been on the podcast
she's she's uh
awesome gal uh it seemed pretty easy
to get it here well freaking kai's
carrying right now in california you got
to give 200 ipads
in texas you just got to buy one beer
you know
it's a very different preferably that
you bring your beard to the license
that's right
you get one beer and we'll give it a
like they want to find a reason to give
you a license well this this this
makes the story a little more
understandable now it's like you can't
even get one yeah you can freaking
navy seal over here can't get one yeah
meanwhile i get it
it's it's becoming a little clearer but
i will tell you though this
what what got me thinking is what mike
said which is
has this happened more often you know is
there hey we'll give you 50 iphones
we'll give you 20 iphones we'll give you
80 ipads
is that a method of a currency of
exchange to get favors that's
interesting if you think about it i
think even
by the way everybody knows i'm a tim
cook guy i'm a guy that actually likes
tim cook's style of what he does but at
the same time if this is
common where some of the leaders at the
bottom are doing it tim cook may not be
may not even know about this well
more likely tim cooking authorizing this
kind of of course not
of course how many employees does does
apple have is it 400 000
mike you were saying well i was just
going to say you know to me the biggest
point is
is you know contrast that to any other
donations that apple has made like
patrick said
they're not known for for doing that so
uh you know whether whether they're
doing it on a regular basis or not
i would be real curious to know you know
have they made ipad iphone imac
donations to other government entities
where they're not trying to get
something from them and again if there
are
a number of those cases where it's it's
not a quid pro quo where they're not
scratching their back and i'll give you
this for that and whatever then i would
say okay
you have a case that you could separate
those two but if this is the only
instance
where they've donated that amount of
equipment to a government agency and it
just so happens to be the government
agency that they're trying to get
uh concealed weapons permits i mean
that's a hard thing to uh
you know to separate here's a fun
question obviously quid pro quo has been
a term we've all become familiar with
over the last few years
is that a term you were even familiar
with in your navy seal days is that
something that was actually the first
three words i learned
i didn't say
i was milking my parents from the start
tell you what dad i'll give you this
yeah
you were looking for that license to
carry permit at zero years old fetus
you